bonjour c'est trop troc votre nouveau
jeu quotidien tous les jours j'ai plein
de cadeaux vous offrir mais bon il me
faut quoi d'abord il me faut un candidat
allez venez on y va
[Musique]
c'est là c'est là ouvrez je sais que
vous êtes là il y a
on y va
bonjour bonjour
elles ont chacune un cadeau dans un des
cadeaux il y a un voyage à l'île Maurice
dans un autre cadeau il y a une console
de jeux et dans un autre cadeau c'est un
cadeau nul quoi voilà le cadeau pas de
bol quoi donc vous choisissez un des
trois cadeaux mais en contrepartie
attention je vais vous demander de me
troquer un objet de chez vous
un objet
ce qu'il faut que je dise c'est que
c'est moi qui choisis
quand même un voyage à l'île Maurice une
console de jeux ou alors le cadeau pas
de bol le cadeau il y a rien quoi mais
ça vous branche on y va alors je vais
demander à Maître véreux notre notre
huissier de justice de bien vouloir vous
faire signer le papier comme quoi vous
êtes d'accord pour nous troquer quelque
chose contre un des cadeaux
alors vous choisissez quel cadeau le
bleu vous êtes sûr le bleu vous êtes sûr
ok c'est parti donc elles ont choisi le
bleu et à moi de choisir maintenant
allez on rentre allez non pas tout le
monde oh là là comme c'est on vous a pas
dérangé du tout vous étiez en train de
déjeuner je suis en train de manger
d'accord
ils sont bien ces fauteuils
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ici
la télé la télé alors la télé non la
télé non c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ça me plaît pas regardez dans
la cuisine
regarder dans la cuisine
j'ai pas mangé moi donc
[Musique]
une collection de capsules de quoi de
champagne de champagne qu'est-ce que
c'est joli
ah ouais ça c'est top
ça c'est top il y a même celle de
Jacques Chirac dis donc
c'est top ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
prend ça
ils sont costauds
quelques années c'est un peu con d'avoir
trois questions
oui mais c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
sinon
faut pas les mettre ça dans le camion
maintenant qu'on a ça on va demander à
une de vos filles de d'aller ouvrir le
cadeau bleu alors vous avez choisi le
cadeau bleu et ben allez-y les filles
suspense
[Musique]
une console de jeux
ça commence par X et ça finit par box
mais on n'a pas retenu
nos premiers clients de trotrock ça vous
a plu
bon ben on se dit au revoir alors au
revoir bisous
[Musique]
merci beaucoup en tout cas allez je
tiens voilà les enfants en plus c'est
des jeux voilà et amusez-vous bien allez
au revoir au revoir et merci je crois
que j'ai fait des heureux
[Musique]